bro you know this app cameo
that where you can like be on Cameo and
you can record personal messages for
people who are fans of yours I got on
Cameo every anytime there's a new app I
get on it because I I feel like I should
be on the new [__] never know what's
going to become the next Instagram
whatever and I also like doing social
media and I never know if I'm gonna like
it until I already use it for a bunch so
I got the app cameo
and these [__] dude I got Cameo
and I put it on for a thousand dollars
because I saw other people doing them
for like 50 bucks a dude here's the deal
okay
I'm not recording personal messages for
people for like [__] thirty dollars a
pop dude I'm not going out there hey
Jason heard it was your birthday
crystalia here live it up no dents and
send it to him like and then you get
that for [__] 30 it's not worth it to
me okay be a fan cool not recording
personal messages all day to make
[__] 700 you know what I'm saying
this is not my bag also so I put it up I
was like what's the most I could charge
a thousand bucks no way I'm doing it for
less than a thousand bucks no [__]
way so couldn't do it from work because
Cameo wouldn't let you you think I
wouldn't do it for 50 Grand you're out
of your [__] mind dude I want to be
the most expensive guy on Cameo don't
give a [__] okay I I I uh so I did it
got a few requests actually got like
seven requests for a cameo person I'm
like bro I'm gonna make seven Grand off
this [__] so all of a sudden I'm like
all right maybe I'll do it even though I
don't want it did one okay
two things happen felt cheap as [__]
because I was like uh you can't
what am I gonna do like 90 of these and
they're gonna be all over the Internet
like hey [__] Alyssa
hope your bar mitzvah was good bar mitz
what do you call them for chicks
pick one
you know
pick your [__] I hope your Mitzvah
was good I'm calling them all Mitzvahs
from now on hope your Mitzvah was good
and then
and then that's it and I'm not gonna do
I'm gonna do seven of these no so then I
was like all right I might not do it
again then I found out Cameo takes 25
percent
bro I I look Cameo respect your hustle
but also you uh-oh you want to take that
much money from me
so I didn't do another one okay not
doing another one unless I can charge
out the [__] anus you understand me
dude
I'm not doing it dude it's too you got
to draw the line somewhere I'm not hey
new app
new app give your phone number to fans
for 50 bucks they can call you whenever
they want no a [__] you out of your mind
dude
um
so I you know so they took [__] 25 of
this [__] and I'm like all right so I'm
never doing it again
dude I swear to God they
the people on Cameo they email me they
text me they [__] do all the shits
they're like hey you got booked again I
don't give a [__] okay I respect your
hustle all good do what you got to do
because
[Music]
I get it
but no dude
I'm not doing it all right I'll make
money other ways so
they got me on their goddamn website
like you can get a cameo from me
you can't all right I didn't know that
they put me on their [__] website
either I didn't know that [__] bro if
you could put me on the [__] if I can
charge 50k for a shout out so I can
boy
my point is look at look at these people
charging this [__] for look at this look
at this uh Chuck Liddell what's he
charged for this thing can we tell 125
bucks for a shout out
okay fine now look that guy I don't know
if he's got money in like real estate or
some [__] his fighting career is
probably you know
he's probably not fighting too much
anymore I get it he's I'm sure he's made
millions of dollars I think scroll up
Lance Bass Brett Favre Brett Favre 500
bucks why what the [__] is Brett Favre
doing this for does he's got a Skechers
deal or some [__]
uh
uh you know these influencers I get
Brittany furlon the doctor Drew 198
dollars the [__] is this [__]
I love Dr Drew
[__] is he doing 198 also and make it
200. what are you a [__]
what do you uh a pair of speakers
look at it Paulie Shore 150 Paulie fine
Brian Callan 100 the [__] are you doing
the [__] are you doing
God makes a million dollars on his
goddamn podcast the [__] does he need a
hundred dollars to say hey Craig hope
you're having a good uh [__] 25th
birthday
Joey Fatone
Kevin O'Leary the [__] billionaire on
Shark Tank for 9.99
what the [__] is he doing
bro don't you own
Earth
what is wrong with these [__]
what the [__] is wrong with everybody on
Cameo for real honestly
well look at this look at this look at
this look at this [__] go up look at
look somebody's my [__] [__]
look at this [__] Ryan Cabrera forty
dollars
tell them more who's this Ruth
Johnny Damon 100 guys
this guy's attract for like 3 000
million in [__] 2009 and he's hey
what's up Johnny Damon here used to play
for the [__] bow Sox just want to
wish you a happy anniversary to you and
your wife
go ahead Slugger for a hundred [__]
dollars you guys can make 75 off this
[__] because Cameo takes his [__]
[__] glass everywhere if it ain't
about no money I understand Johnny
Damon
is this is unbelievable this [__] Neo
dude
135 that dude Neo seriously makes for
real 50 million dollars just stepping
into Europe
he just steps onto European land and
makes 50 million dollars okay this guy's
charging 125 for a person you know what
how about this
no no [__]
uh now I'm not only I'm not on Cameo
anymore for that I'm buying a [__]
personalized message to Neo from Neo
that's what I'm [__] doing right now
after this podcast I am purchasing a
[__] personalized message from Neo
I'm gonna give him 125 because I want
him to be like yo what's up Chris Delia
hey how you doing it's Neo even though
this dude makes 50 million dollars as
soon as the [__] Learjet door
[Music]
opens in [__] Sweden as soon as that
[__] opens a guy shows up with a
briefcase and goes here's 50 mil cash
and Neo [__] Moonwalks backwards into
the [__] plane and goes back you
don't even need to perform I'm gonna buy
a [__] shout out from Neo on Cameo
straight up
so hopefully we'll have it by next week
why am I not doing this but why am I not
buying all these by the way I'm buying
all these motherfuckings
why have I not thought of this
it's unbelievable I haven't thought of
this